ha ha shower you doing like this water
max nice to pee and anyway I left the
next episode with the note I think and
we need to read it take the cap of
college and get out isn't it lovely to
just start with some reading time I told
him to be careful with the chemicals
those morons didn't listen now have the
castle completely destroyed
for those who will read this and need
some great fire power to crank the open
a door anything you have be careful make
it I thought I did this already what is
this [ __ ]
ok I already get all right the thing is
I already did get it but it's this
secret entrance them stop what is that
what are you doing there darling what
are you doing how much I get it I get it
I pretty much have all that we need so
let's go see you later bro I don't think
the water bras here anymore or the fish
bro I don't know what to call him to be
honest
ah lightning over there isn't that fun
time where's oh I got the prisoner key
now I get it all right
all right look I blow this up there's a
Santa thing as a cockroach more wall
gliding I love that [ __ ] alright and now
we whoa shot me scare the [ __ ] out of me
alright here we go now we need to go
back to the place on whatever that is
it's a good question I think it's over
here
fabric garlic question cc I mean weally
alright then it's a over here thing
oh it's right ask anything the painting
I love that [ __ ] did it all it I was
about hey I was like doing movements and
stuff that's that's how I roll
that's how I got all the ladies in
kindergarten just hey there you want to
see my finger painting girl when I was
five I don't know what I'm talking about
that was probably crying in the corner
when I was five all right here we go
all right what is this I need to go to
the prison I don't really want to go to
the prison prison door key required
isn't that your nice coincidence oh [ __ ]
me that's two bad things in one sentence
hello that that is this hello
let's check the boxes as you go Maxis
got an A in to inter in whatever for me
a minute I'll be sure to do that it's
not a lever up there oh thank you boxes
it's called pity my brush whoa
I did this do well don't mind
bon by ash boxes I bid you farewell and
good luck clap it you need it oh [ __ ] me
what is this Oh No so many dead people
and dead legs like my least favorite
part of the Dead part little rats making
love goddamnit
the horrible place here to anyone who
will ever read this knowledge I have to
stand a lot of things in my life but
suffer that much i days a very slow
second like field minutes now round
entities and glad at all o'clock still
works at least him in know when this
monster this thing was doing this to me
always wanted to add this gaza monsters
do want the castles they want to party
but ain't no party like a people own
this castle was built by my grandparents
and i the only child in this family
could be in one to inherit it I feel
like these are my last days there I hear
them coming better hide
whoever is its careful it was find
yourself more and safe inside the
mansion that's what [ __ ] who did that
that hard freaking me miserable [ __ ]
laughs thank you very much
oh not you again whoa what did I do
take em alright cold why can't we be
friends
oh I knew you were a poke back I know it
let me take that got the hammer not
looking at your penis
oh yeah damn it Marty Wow
shut up Wally not supposed to be here
all right we're done here let's go we
got the camera so we need to go out
again it's funny how Oh certain the
secrets here secrets no all right fine
was that fapping sound shut up not that
sexy
goddammit okay so now we go in here
again and use the hammer on the door if
you remember it was right there
somewhere
I know you love me I know you care sad
for never and now be a share why do I
know the lyric all right
finger painting door and it's right here
right now oh it looks like a peopIe
party over there that's cool excuse the
hammer
oh snap Hulk mode whoa what the hell
this is a total lame PewDiePie party but
okay I'll roll with it
hey how you doing you come here often
how about you you party here often
ah nicest group dance going there let me
just get that whoa now finally they are
starting to party like yeah
pig pies here how did I pick up mansion
key oh cool
all right it says I gotta go as fast as
possible but otherwise I'll be here and
defeat my party ain't no party like a
Peter Pan party it's ba ba ba ba boo ba
party no it's not here
why did I go here where's the man
No maybe it's a maybe no it's not I'm an
idiot but that's okay
it's how life works sometimes the
mansion is over here
excuse me darts while I open here the
mansion is ever yeah I think in this
door isn't it a fantastic moment when
you realize yeah that's all right
lovely sky by the way you might spend
time when I was in that place that I was
awesome so I had to refer to it sir
I couldn't display my all right here we
go
hey flowers this isn't so bad after all
even the flowers with himself that's a
problem all right let's go into the
mansion finish it I guess this is the
last map or whatever maybe I don't know
well there was another door that didn't
[ __ ] open but Oh
what yeah I don't trust you all you
thought I was gonna forget you girl
you'll die ahead Pandit what is a real
girl a boy whatever you are think you're
a boy girl that look yeah oh you try to
place this here so I wouldn't get past
what not me sorry I can't really hear
you oh this is texture huh what
what can you please talk normal
seriously he's got some sort of brain
haha that was a laugh oh really
oh no I servants I'm coming to get you
naked man whoa I'm coming to get you
no one [ __ ] with map parody I dished a
purified party to get beer you know all
right I needs to find like a goo or
whatever lord stratums ki ha ha ha I
ever knew I had it but that's cool so I
guess there was another matter
lots of loading in this episode that's
okay hey flower power
aren't you sweet love you flowers
everywhere this looks kind of common
eyes I like it
whoa so that's where the creatures come
from and looks very weak oh I have to
pass through this is gonna be a problem
all right in three one two go Oh a lot
all right and yep
what
and a whip alright Mack dead Oh seeing
on his chest I need to find a way to
break the curse maybe kill him
no maybe a sex change now Alice not that
was a solid to everything but apparently
not
alright so I need something to break the
spell god damn it I don't have anything
to break the spell maybe Jennifer I'll
have a pickpocket every time I got a
jump through again
ow don't hurt me that hurts every time I
find naked man go up here ah so many sad
are you kidding
this huh I got damn it another map press
set what is this I'm gonna die by like a
duker oh hell no oh no dead people oh no
Wally what did you do
Wally not cool why no no no no no
everyone just chill let's go we're in a
prison
no no no no it's codes go let's go I'll
just help you later cuz you look pretty
dead so I don't really know it's cold
it's cold it's cold go oh you're dead Oh
Ladon a man and bread bread you look
delicious and a bit moldy but I don't
think we can get along anyway what do
you think about this situation it's the
father will never begin help you you
know what right don't tell me secret I
have started the key on the other side
of the mansion the warden the [ __ ] does
that mean
I need find a key for this cabinet it's
on the other side of this mansion behind
those bars but how the [ __ ] here no I
don't get it actually Shh stop
complaining this is this wonder what the
hell that does not look fun
I don't know why but there's always a
lever I miss somewhere yeah look at that
[ __ ] ah goddammit whoa whoa why do you
do that Oh No
all right there we go there you are you
[ __ ] ball I'm gonna penetrate you
that's right you like that [ __ ] all
right
no no no no no take the ball down mate I
don't like his hiding spot all right
I knew it was a perfect I knew it
need to jail up in that metal bird I'm
like [ __ ] in it what is that oh I got
the song which we're gonna use the bars
down there and then there I will
probably find it
damn it you open that's right that's
right
[ __ ] off hey bad you look cool today all
stop complaining you never go in
anywhere in life without attitude now
damn is frigging tricky stuff man tricky
stuff I keep looking everywhere and be
like where is that I don't get at your
are lucky for things all right let's
just go over here and check the drill
thing Bell I need to get rid of that
[ __ ] fence that's right try that [ __ ]
that's right I think my drill is stuck
though but that's cool even though it's
it's oh no all right
not afraid of this [ __ ] anymore
there we go machine room in the next
episode because goddamn there's a lot of
tricky puzzles in this one my brain is
starting to melt I think all right here
we go
[Music]
the asses